siamo già ospita pratica un giorno sono
andata a dormire a casa di questo mio
amico mi svegli una mattina da non
potere andare al bagno questo c'è il
bagno in camera
ho trovato che sta in pratica tutto
nessuno sta della sorella voi tipo con
gli orsacchiotti grandi sul lavandino
tesi stare in gruppo russo qualche
cinico ma che stai facendo per questo si
gira nudo posso essere comprato il pacco
io per l'imbarazzo non avrei mai detto
ma che stai facendo è la cosa che mi
turba di più di tutto il racconto povera
la ragazza moreno tdp l'area se poi
story fosse vero posso superare questo
momento
[Musica]
ciao ragazzi bentornati una nuova
puntata di vita buttata il tema della
puntata di oggi è amici strani
per una puntata così importante ho
pensato di invitare all'interno degli
studios di casa mia
innanzitutto una delle persone che mi
conosce meglio al mondo e che quindi più
di chiunque altro ha testimoniato la mia
sanità mentale è inoltre uno degli
ospiti secondo me più amati a seconda di
quello che leggo dai vostri commenti qui
su questo canale
purtroppo non poteva venire quindi alla
fine abbiamo optato per claudia genolini
la prossima volta metterò delle lance
qui salve a tutti buona sera
sa che cosa non apprezzo molto i knicks
e magra ma mi fa sembrare della giumenta
ea più avanti così ognuno capitolari
mettere un po di cose da dire
evitiamo di di noi prospetta un caro
amico che con la pelle morta delle mani
lui se sfogliava piano piano piano piano
aveva fatto con la penna un buco nel
banco che ogni giorno riempiono questo
buco di questa pagina
io preferirei una ziggurat di caccole
una sciarpa di palline dell'ombelico sa
questo 93 sfogliato stuccando ha
riempito kiss kiss ragazze auguriamo
ospiti io ho un amico che si è stata
tirata e che viaggia che di oliva da
qualsiasi cosa deve fare lui sui parchi
e di una volta si è fatto il giro
d'italia chiede se le cose sgam però ho
paura delle formiche perché pezzo egli
possa entrare dentro l'orecchio e
mangiarsi o ha dovuto il petrolio ha
mangiato testo di sua sorella direi che
basta così domenica ha mangiato un pezzo
di sua sorella l'ha detto ho capito male
io comunque credo sia alla base proprio
della sua dieta è come la mano intorno
alla casa del pirata cioè un pilota ma
va in giro a piedi non va con la nave
perché non c'è il mare quindi va in giro
e fa cazza la randa domani giro su una
camera
ma seduto sull'asfalto visibili così
ciao quegli anni e già ospite adesso di
avere una delle amiche più strane del
mondo a tante particolarità però una
delle più inquietanti ma affascinanti
allo stesso tempo è che sanno parlare
completamente insorto e se non ci credi
guarda c'era un proprio qua ciao marty
presenti o è meglio con la sanità e
hoster andrà pilota lo perdono russo e
se non siete ancora convinti
adesso vi facciamo qualche altro esempio
ingrato cielo e le chat org
l'asciugamano una libreria erbil
lampadario occhiali e laico
supercalifragilistichespiralidoso ecco
rosa questa mi dispiace che li voglio un
sacco di bene è strana lo dice veramente
al contrario enrico il montaggio
prendi quello che dice e lo ribalti pie
adesso stiamo ascoltando vai libreria
asciugamano grattacielo faccio delle
reazioni capito occhiali ici dozza
armadio poi
ora in poi d'ambra armadio per che più
stanno devastando ridendo aogo sappi che
ti amo saluta anche l'ospite mia lista
di essere etero e vorrei cambiare idea
per te però io conosco questo mio amico
qua che ogni mattina prende la bilancia
per pesare la droga è presente l'erba
non abbiamo presente per scottate quindi
prende il peso delle fette biscottate e
ci aggiunge per forza se no mi ha detto
che non riesce ad andare avanti nella
giornata 8 grammi di marmellata per
ognuna e quindi fa 12 grammi di fetta
biscottata più hot di marmellata per tre
marmellate in modo da fare 37 biscottate
perfette da 20 grammi in tutto questo a
me mi ha turbato la bilancia per la dry
e io e andrea mati sulla bilancia perché
rei di non averla qualsiasi tipo letto
di breve catena del mio nome
6 eisenberg ai maledettamente ragione io
sono un pochino sensi o offensivo cioè
le fisse 22 a periodi non hai sempre la
stessa fissa cioè coerente nel fisso ma
lo sono coerente in generale anche tu
sei quella lì tipo che non sa usare la
diplomazia e stata la regina del
bipolarismo e tu sei la regina delle di
odio
io conoscevo una persona assistita
compulsive la conoscevi anche tu matteo
bruno
beh a parte manca un bruno matola
metteva mai calzini dello stesso colore
marco ascoltano stata ospitata trasforma
con la mia vita per guardare alcune
fisco e l'amico viti da chi andare assai
dormire tranquilla se le sue scarpe non
sono perfettamente posizionate una
fianco all'altra neanche sono fidato che
un giorno ad esempio delle scarpe nuove
le fanno particolarmente male oppure si
stanca a camminare quelli che fanno male
piedi le per cognizione non le mette
vicino la notte ma mette il sun è un
anno fa parte né dall'altra
addirittura le forme dei tagli e delle
vesciche rilancia e batte da una parte
all'altra sempre per posizione cattivo
però perché lei magari si mangia le
scarpe pallone qual è la cosa più strana
che fai tu non so quanto sia strana
piace credere che sia una cosa che fanno
più persone faccio tipo delle scommesse
con me stesso tipo
se il semaforo scatta altre allora
succede questo oppure faccio il
giochetto pari di spanò cioè di sparo
succede una cosa pari succede un'altra
cosa quindi comincia a fare 1 2 3 4 e
quando scatta tu sai che ho succede una
cosa succede un'altra cosa io direi che
è un'ottima materia di studio e poi mi
mangio le feci questa cosa e scorsa
faccio anch'io non puoi copiare maglione
pezzi enrico e il peggio di tu eri così
onesto jami lo accetto è meno strano e
più disconnesso però
disturbato e adesso si è spostato
l'argomento ma lui è stato bravo a
spostarlo andiamo avanti
chi è il più strano della famiglia ok il
podio mettete e gabriele e quindi la mia
tranquilla una persona sana scala
richter della pazzia
avete i prototipi il no i prodotti più
importati ma si può dire che prototipico
prototipo attira riserve tuo fratello è
importante ma di famiglia io ho notato
che toma dalla stessa risata se non la
fa adesso non l'ha fatta guardano con
giudizio senso delle cose brutte su di
lui mentre le delibere un amico che si
diverte tantissimo a spolverare i finali
i film delle tv
chiunque però questo non essere estranei
questa sera se col tempo lo capirai
perché rimani solo più che altro cioè
come dire è mio amico si diverte un
sacco a incendiarsi le scure la gente
magari col tempo imparerà mai ragazzi
tu l'hai mai fatto fare le puzze con
l'accendino sul sedere io non ho mai
fatto
vorrei una casa è strano vorrei tanto
farlo stati però bisogna farlo col jeans
perché sennò c'è il ritorno di fiamma e
muori
se volete farlo fatelo con il gii non
fatelo e pericolosi se che lo voglio
fare troppa da trent'anni dire che tutto
si passa e che pensa che bello questa
fiamma blu che poi il metano cia dei
colori strani non potevo la rara boreale
de l'aurora boretto re ha già ospitato
mio amico era alle prime armi con i
motori di non così il padre si offrì
volontario per praticare delle guide in
una di queste volte lui a questo troppa
velocità prendendosi conto troppo tardi
di una curva così pensò bene di
lanciarsi giù dal mezzo lasciando che il
padre si schiantasse da solo no lui era
alla guida
ho conosciuto una ragazza che una volta
che ha rosicato col suo ragazzo stavano
in macchina e stavano andando abbastanza
veloci loro due litigano costa voglio
andarmene temere tesi sulla tangenziale
tutto questo avveniva lei ha buttato la
borsa dal finestrino e ha detto ora
costi ora i costi non me ne frego la
borsa asita rifrattura dalla spalla alle
coste i costi creda fatti si dovrebbe
dire coste tutti quanti medicina fuori
le costole non sono tipo le costolette
del maiale e le coste sono il costato
vabbè le costole serata si è rotta le
coste quindi la cosa più assurda di
questa cosa io ho detto roster non come
pizia si è lanciato dalla macchina di
una volta col motorino prima volta che
salgo vado per spingerlo per salirci
sopra motore acceso spingerlo in che
senso
enrico qualcosa ho fatto così unione si
fatto esplodere il parabrezza
allo strutto sì se poi mi hanno
sopportato senza il parabrezza
siamo arrivati alla fine di questa
puntata grazie mille per tutti i
messaggi che ci avete mandato grazie
soprattutto a claudio anche per claudio
detto fate visionare qui sotto se
conoscete qualche personaggio
particolare se tra le nostre amicizie si
annovera qualcuno così peculiare
potrebbe dirla più semplice
scrivetemi se conoscete qualcuno che
strano qua sotto vabbè come sempre io vi
saluto vi invito a iscrivervi al mio
canale ai canali di claudia attivare le
notifiche fare tutto come fate una
giravolta fate era un'altra volta mette
telai che ci vediamo la prossima
settimana con un'altra puntata sempre le
14 ciao ciao